derrière vous avez une télé où on peut
avoir de la trois dimensions sans
lunettes ça vous permet d'avoir avec vos
yeux directement un effet en trois
dimensions je trouve ça absolument
dingue de pas avoir besoin d'avoir vos
petites lunettes sur la tronche pour
avoir la 3D Alors on se parle ici d'une
dalle 65 pouces c'est très grand 8k
grosse résolution c'est pas aussi bien
que si vous avez des lunettes 3DS si
vous allez regarder par exemple avatar
ou sinon je soyons clair mais il y a un
petit effet marrant alors il faut
vraiment être là donc si vous avez des
convives sur le côté l'effet se perd un
peu donc à voir si ça pourrait arriver
peut-être dans quelques années avec un
suivi du regard alors attendez suivre le
regard de tout le monde je suis pas
convaincu mais lino est là elle est
marrante elle essayait TCL d'ailleurs
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires est-ce que ça pourrait vous
tenter un truc comme ça ou alors
absolument pas marqué